okay so I haven't been talking much
about this right-wing journalist named
Andy no it's spelled NGO I've been told
it's pronounced no I'm going to
pronounce it that way today and I'm
gonna talk about him today a little bit
now I know for a fact that a significant
portion of my audience has not even
heard of this guy they're not aware of
the controversy involving Andy no but at
this point I think it does warrant a
discussion even if you haven't been
following the story because Andy know is
just the worst kind of right-wing
grifter that's what I've learned over
the last couple of months so I'm gonna
explain the entire thing to you Andy no
is an early 30s 30 to 33 year old
right-wing journalist his parents came
to the United States from Vietnam he's
an asian-american he was born and raised
in the United States in Portland Oregon
and he was known prior to June of 2019
in some niche circles for writing for a
publication named Colette and in June he
was propelled to significantly more
notoriety and fame because he was
assaulted at a protest by an Tifa
protestors in Portland Oregon
there was a right-wing proud boy March
in Portland Oregon
there was an aunt Aoife counter protest
and Andino was there and he was attacked
he was punched he was milkshakes I mean
really bad stuff I unconditionally
denounced it I haven't talked more about
the broader and II know stuff but the
attacks on him I denounced I'm against
violence it's horrible we shouldn't be
doing this to anyone a period okay and
people were saying oh and Ino was
baiting an Tifa to attack him merely by
being there because people know what
he's written in the past okay look at
that that all may be true but the
violence is completely out of line I'm
against the violence period horrible
full-stop not no other qualifiers are
necessary now when that happened when he
was attacked
of course predictably he immediately got
a media round of interviews as a result
and the media interviews mostly set him
up to talk about how violent the left is
and how bad an Tifa is he was on Dave
Rubens show he was on Joe Rogan's show I
think he was on Fox News he was all over
the place and fascinatingly a lot of the
coverage was identity politics coverage
saying look at this small in stature gay
Asian guy who was attacked by left
wingers even though he checks identity
boxes that the left should be defending
or or in favor of or whatever I mean
it's a total identity politics argument
we know that the right claims to be
against identity politics except when
they're for it
because it benefits them in some way
shape or form but then things started to
sort of not make sense about andino so
first of all he had claimed that the
Milkshakes that were thrown at him which
I'm against period the milkshakes that
were thrown at him contained concrete
which of course would conceivably Harden
and do serious damage to a human body
but there appears to be no actual
evidence that there was any concrete
there so that started to be sort of a
weird thing then I asked myself when I
watched interviews with this guy why
does Andy know sort of speak in a
British accent now when if you look at
videos from just a few years ago he had
a standard American accent and he was
raised in Portland Oregon it's no crime
to adopt a random accent we know what
was it Madonna has done it right but the
people that do that it's an odd thing to
do and often for me it's signals that
there may be sort of more to the person
it's rare that all they do that raises
questions is adopt an accent that
doesn't correspond to where they were
raised okay but then it gets really bad
journalistically okay and Ino starts
reporting that at another Portland
Oregon protest and Tifa attacked
right-wingers with hammers he tweeted
and Tifa attacks people on a bus they
try to pull them out and hit him with a
hammer and from the video he posted it's
sort of maybe seems plausible but very
quickly more videos surfaced and you
actually see that the ante for we might
call them the counter protesters were
pounding on the windows of a bus
containing right-wingers
a white nationalist group and it's
actually the right-wingers in the bus
who introduce a hammer literally the
opposite of what this guy and Ino
reports and the people on the bus again
they were either right-wing American
Guard which is a right-wing supremacist
white supremacist group or maybe proud
boys or a combination of the two so the
story is literally the opposite of what
and Ino reports and then what and Ino
follows up with is oh right it was the
right-wingers who introduced the hammers
but they were doing it in self-defense
which is now a completely different
story I mean really a grifter tweeting
quote the mob rushed the buses as they
were trying to leave and began attacking
the vehicles with concrete before
attacking the people inside the buses
could not continue driving because
protesters were standing in front in
that context the use of the hammer may
have been in self-defense so this is not
a good faith actor he first reports that
an Tifa brandished hammers then when it
becomes undeniable that it was the right
wingers who brandished the hammers he
says all right that's true the opposite
of what I reported is true but it was
plausibly in self-defense so not a good
faith actor even though he's being
lauded by the right and then the cherry
on top is that he now has been caught on
video commiserating with a far-right
group that was planning violence and he
never reported that they were planning
this violence the group is called
patriot prayer they were planning
violence knows on video hanging out with
them as they plan it he reported nothing
and now it has been announced that he is
no longer with quill let the publication
for which he worked
now colette is saying that the
separation is not directly related to
the fact that he's been exposed as
commiserating with right wingers
planning violence and said nothing about
it they say he actually left colette
weeks ago and they're only announcing it
now maybe that's true maybe it's not i
don't know the truth of that so the big
picture is first of all not surprisingly
someone that the right decided to hold
up as both a martyr and a hero of sorts
is not either of those things and really
is a bad faith actor who was attacked
and i am against the violence and he
shouldn't have been punch and milkshake
okay i want to be absolutely in total
but when you put it all together I just
see a troubled guy quite frankly the
combination of his completely dishonest
and contradictory reporting again the
starting to speak with this British
accent a couple of years ago which I
know people will say David that doesn't
really mean anything I agree it's a
detail but if you zoom out and look at
the the big picture here
taken with anything else to me it
signals a troubled and confused person
and this is someone that we are better
off seeing for what they are which is
really an unreliable and very partial
right wing we can use the term
journalist we can we can use the term
activist we can use the term analyst or
commentator I don't know exactly what
term to use but now that we've sort of
let it all play out over the last couple
of months I think the truth of Andino is
surfacing and I've even seen tweets and
retweets from people who interviewed
andino and gave them the platform to
talk about how bad everybody is to him
and how bad the left isn't all of this
different stuff they are even pointing
out that things have certainly turned
and taken a different direction with
Andino if you don't care about this guy
or didn't know about him and quite
frankly continue not to care fair I
totally understand that if you've been
following this I would be curious to
hear from you I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
have has your view changed about Andy no
from the beginning in June when when
this story and his being attacked came
to prominence to now has your view
changed or has it not was it always a
negative view does it remain positive I
want to hear from you I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and i hope you will join me
this week this this week I will be doing
once or twice in the evening live twitch
streams at twitch.tv slash david pakman
make sure you're following me there and
I hope to see you at one of my streams
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka is a
great service that I use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to and you still get the most
crucial information and insights from
each book and I've listened to a ton of
books on blink Asst I recently checked
out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on bling cos they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
is calm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube I'm putting a link in the
video description and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa que mas